Did you know in China they have a breakup tax?
like for example,
let's say you date a girl
a beautiful girl
say she's 20 to 25
that's her peak
the opinion in Asia is their best looking/
highest value years are from age 20 to 25
in their culture
after 30, their value goes down
if you date a woman from age 20 to 25 and you don't marry her
you have to pay her
cause you took the best years of her life
the guy has to pay and depending on how beautiful she is how smart she is
is she a lawyer etcetera that's how much you have to pay
she's a lawyer and she's beautiful
you have to pay like 200 k because you took the best years of her life
and now no guy wants her because she's past her prime